Welcome to Google Developers Show.
I'm Nicolas Bortolotti.
In this new emission we'll keep working on data
and massive data analysis.
We'll also check Polymer technology
in our "Reverse Focus" section. We'll present this new approach of web development.
Alright, we're now in our "Reverse Focus" section.
We'll see an application developed in Polymer.
We'll work on the first application we've manipulated and did queries to the massive data,
but in this particular case, the data goes to Polymer,
So let's see our code in big size as we developers like.
First, we'll see the development scenario of Polymer. To do so we'll use
the master tutorial of Polymer, from Polymer's team.
This will let as understand much better the concepts of Polymer. After this we'll go to
the solution that we already have developed to build the front end, the aesthetic part, using Polymer,
and the same query to the massive data that we used in the "Reverse Focus" of the previous show.
So let's go to work on that.
As you can see here we already have
our structure of the Polymer Tutorial Master. The structure that Polymer propose has the API and the interaction
with Polymer. Then it propose us a Starter scenario where we can use
the starter part. Here we'll do a simple exercise to work the Index and some elements
of Polymer.
If we're not so sure about it, we can go, step by step. I mean, we began from the Starter in the
step 1, 2 and 3 to complete all the learning and learn much more about Polymer.
Let's see what this solution is about. I'll use
inside the root a file named
Index.html, where the solution is
basically finished, or a solution that we
want to implement in Polymer.
As you can see, inside this file, we
have initially the header of the html file.
In this particular case we have links to different elements of Polymer that we're working
from the Bower Components.
Then we hvae the styles, in this particular case we're working with a link to the core toolbar,
and with a link to the paper tabs to other html that we embed from this structure.
Then we have the styles
and finally, in the body, we have the operation.
First, we'll see how to work this solution in full mode.
To do so, we'll take out all the comments
so you can se how this application
behaves. Basically, we take out the coments of the first part, that will do the interaction with a tabs panel
where we'll be able to select a conteiner, and here we have the intereaction with the final
graphic, where we want to show
the graphics. So let's start using this.
I'll  put a http server using Python. Here, in the Python
console - m $impleHTTPServer so we can have it available. We authorize the "allow"
so we cab have our server working.
Join me! Let's go to our browser in the 8000 port of the local host. As you can see
we already have our tabs interaction ready, a conteiner, and the graphic. So now let's see
step by step, how this solution builds really quickly.
We'll see three blocks of codes. One will mount the first bar, the second one will mount the content
and in the third one, we'll mount the
interaction simulated with the data graphic
for now.
So, we go back here to continue with our functional server. Let's work commenting
the 2 segments of codes that we don't want to see initially. To do so let's use this option
as Ide of development. In this particular case I'm still using PhyCharm, as a matter of convenience.
You know I'm an enthusiastic of Python development!
Let's go to this point then, and we'll ony comment on this second one and we'll only see the
header panel core, this is the initial header. Then we'll see the tabs, in this case we have two
tabs, one that refers to all, and the other one to favorites. And finally we also have a conteiner here that
we could also hide or not, we'll let it available in this case. We then save.
Or server keeps working in the 8000 port,
we reload the page in the 8000 port,
and as you can see, we have our panel and our conteiner. Let's remove the second conteiner,
so we can keep seeing the elements. And here we'll see the tabs, just as interactions.
So this way, we have the interaction with the styles in he tab. After this we can generate
many conteiners depending of what we want to do.
I can also list the conteiners
In this case, we'll remove the comment, very easily.
To list these conteiners I have to use the post-cart label, and I'll also shoe how I'm linking
these post cart in this element, Let's go out from this Index.html that we have here. And here we have
the post-cart, the element that I'm embedding, in this particular case. In Polymer, is very easy
to do this embedding actions
where you can see that this html content is already available
for me to set it up from the Index.
I can do the same thing with Google Chart.
What I'm doing there is to bring
that information that is
located in Google chart html, as I do it in the post card html, and embedding in the Index.html
with some parameters that I've been chaning. This way we can see
how Polymer allows us very quickly to do this operations, but here we're doing so
in a simulated way. Let's remove the comment, and here we have some
java script, Done. And we have the conteiner that simulates the final graphic. So let's add that.
We go back here, our server keeps working, we have our tab, we have our conteiner
and our graphic.
Now we'll see how this same operation works but brining the data form BigQuery,
as we've been working on it in our previous "Reverse Focus" segment (previous show).
Let's take a few seconds
because we won't see it right now, as it is our "x".
We'll be right back with much more to come in Google Developers Show and with our "Reverse Focus" segment.
Welcome to "Latam in your hands" segment,
a panel where the voices of the technological development and knowledge of Google technologies
speak up!
In this emission we'll hear about Cine+, a young team with one of the most outstanding applications
in the mobile regional ecosystem.
Cine+ is an application to sell tickets of the
90% of the cinemas in the country.
With the GPS of your smartphone, we show you the closest cinemas and if you don't know
where the cinema is, we show you,
with the help of Google Maps,
where exactly the cinema is and how
you can get there with Google addresses.
In Cine+, we try to have great experiences in mobile applications, specifically in Android.
The first application that we developed was
for Android. We developed the
first prototype in 8 hours in a Google Hackaton, and we moved forward from that start.
I'm in charge of doing the platform development  for Android, and what i like the most is
the versatility of being able to try many things, so every time we want to create a new feature
that is quite complexi, Android has the tools to do so.
We like to use it because
we can try things very easily. The waiting time in the store takes just 2 hours and then the user can
enjoy the new experience. We also use
other services like App Engine
that saves us the time to create the infrastructure from 0.
We just take care of doing the code, the
front end and that's it, in a few minutes
we have all done and working for the clients.
Alright, we're back in our "Reverse focus" segment. Let's keep working on data in Polymer.
In the first segment, we've been working on Polymer
technology and we saw how to interact (in a simulated way) with the elements that it proposes.
Now we'll work in the direct solution in which we get the data of BigQuery,
following the initial scenary of our Rever Focus segment in the first show, and we bring that data
and we render them using the components of Polymer. Let's
enjoy this technological party. In this
particular case we keep working
on the code. As you can see we have
our development in the traditional server,
in the 8000 port of the localhost, where we've
been working with Polymer. Here
we have our development enviroment with our demonstration of Polymer. Let's cancel this because
we don't need it anymore,
and we'll go directly to interact with the solution in BigQuery.
We keep using, in this particular case,
the dashboard of BigQuery that is
dashboard-bigquery as the axis of solution.
And in this solution, we did a connection in BigQuery, we obtain a query in BigQuery,
from a massive data base.
In this case we used as an example the Wikipedia data base and we rendered that information
trough a traditional chart. Now that we remember that scenario we have prepared here an Index.html 1
but we have an Index.html that is the initial
scenario of code that we worked on.
As you can see, we had implemented
a function in Java Script
that received the information in a Jason
format and basically it rendered it
in a graphic. Let's see this solution and how it runs.
To do se we'll use Google App Engine Loucher. Remember
that we're developing the solution with Python, and in this particular case, we have to run
the application like this. We can also configure PhyCharm, and run the application
from the development of the IDE. In this case we'll use Google App Engine Louncher.
As you can see here, I place my solution,
in this case, Dashboard BigQuery.
Let's run it, as you can see it is green now, and we'll browse it.
In this case, the 1980 port runs inside the localhost
and we obtain the query (The execution is done in App Engine),
from BigQuery with the data so we can then
render them in the columns panel
as you can see here in this graphic.
Now we'll do the same, but we'll use Polymer.
So, let's see how to implement this second step.
We need toc reate a html that uses Polymer components.
We'll use Index_1 las the number 1 version
of this Html. The structure
of this html is very simple. We have
a header as you can see here,
we're also calling to a very traditional Java Script, and we do the implementation of this import
that in this case has all the knowledge
of Polymer to render the charts
of Google, in this case.
Now we'll use a combination of Polymer and Web Components. So it is important
that we see how Google chart is implemented.
We already have this chart
that we can obtain from the Web Components page,
as one fo the traditional examples.
As you can see here it is a bit long the
development that Google chart
propose but the knowledge is ready
so we can use it. The only thing
that I'll do in this particular case, is
to implement this element of Google chart.
Once we that implemented with
the importation ready, we'll use a label
of web complements with Polymer that Google Chart
propose, as you can see here.
The only change, and this is the tip
and trick of this implementation
is that we are bringing the data with Data,
remember that I have to put
the " safe" in order to
obtain the data correctly pure from Jason. This way, I'm getting
the data that BigQuery gives me from the query, like we traditionally did in the initial chart.
Let's see now the implementation in Python that we had from the solution in App Engine.
This solution won't change at all. The only thing we'll change is that we order to the HTML
that Jinja 2 takes all the data with
the template that we show you.
So let's see the implementation of main.phy where we have, at the end, the template
where the information is embed in the Index.html
We'll change the Index.html to index_1. html
and the information
will flow to this new component in Polymer
that we've been working on.
Let's see how this application words. We already did the change and we explained how each
of these elements work. Let's go back
to our initial scenario. I'll reload
the application and we'll see how this
element behaves. As you can see
we have the rendered graphic using Polymer.
As you can we review in the Index_1.html
and its title is Demonstration.
In fact, is misspelled. Let's write Demo, so you can see that the graphic that is being
implemented is the graphic that we're
viewing. We go bak to our browser
and in this case we reload the application,
that does the query,
and it is titled Demo. This has been our implementation in
our Rever Focus segment. We brought
the data and we implemented them
using Polymer.
LatinAmerican developers, we've come this far for now in our Google Developers Show.
Don't miss the next episodes!
And keep developing!